why this business why did you want to
get into nuclear five years ago I set
out to solve a problem
carbon had been increasing
access to clean energy is becoming
difficult across parts of the world and
now we even see the problems with energy
security as well and so I founded the
energy Impact Center first just a
research institute to take a first
principles look at our climate and
energy problems across the globe
our investigation our interviewing
subject matter experts across the
country across Academia across industry
across policy makers led us to
understanding that nuclear was the
solution and it had just become stagnant
for unobvious reasons and so we set out
for even more research and more
interviews and more investigation to
figure out why that was
foreign
[Music]
ER and CEO of last energy and we are
here in what's called a mechanical
prototype of your first small nuclear
reactor this is very exciting this
building is what's the size of the
building that we're in now it's a cube
that's 30 feet by 30 feet by 30 feet
okay and within this cube is housed last
Energies
new nuclear reactor so this is kind of
amazing but we've reached a point in the
world where we're really starting to
think about the future of new nuclear
Advanced reactors and so last energy is
working to commercialize this this
future but you're doing it in a very
different way so what I'd like to get
into is is the story of last energy and
what you're doing that's so different
from some of the other companies like
you know GE Hitachi and and Toshiba and
Westinghouse that are trying to build
enormous new power plants tell me what
you're working on
so we've taken is the standard
pressurized water reactor technology
it's the Workhorse of the industry 300
power plants around the world 10 percent
of humankind's electricity is produced
from this power source and we've
productized it miniaturized it and
modularized it in order to make it a
manufacturable product in order to bring
the cost down and increase the
scalability of nuclear energy production
across the world okay so um in recent
months we've seen some big breakthroughs
announced in infusion technology so
nuclear fusion had had a big day in late
2022 um
this was newfangled new stuff that no
one had ever accomplished before tell me
what's new about your Technique yeah
we're Innovative in the way that we are
not actually introducing any new physics
any new chemistry any new Material
Science it's a very different approach
towards energy Technology Innovation we
spent years trying to study what makes
new energy systems work so what makes
new technology work and what we found
over and over again is if you change too
many variables all at the same time back
to that physics or the chemistry
Material Science if you deviate from The
Standard supply chain you find yourself
in a position where every component is
10 times as expensive and you don't
actually make any Headway on cost
reduction our Core Design principle is
use standardized equipment off the shelf
one might say in order to benefit from
the experience of so many other
Industries before us
so all of the skills said is already
here these these guys are accustomed to
building huge equipment for the oil gas
industry fits your your needs perfectly
exactly so we don't even have to invest
in our own facilities to get started we
don't have that huge upfront Capital
toss rather we get to benefit from
already existing facilities and use a
contract manufacturing process in order
to get off the ground years ahead of
schedule
the kind of ethels that they're
manufacturing here these are very common
for the oil and gas industry um how is
it that you can use the same types of
equipment for uh for nuclear yep one of
the benefits that we brought about in
designing our system initially was to
base everything off of the existing oil
and gas supply chain so the oil and gas
industry is already used to dealing with
high pressure systems high flow rates of
water pressure vessels land is pipes you
name it and so by utilizing not only the
existing supply chain but also their
existing facilities in the labor force
and the expertise we're able to hit the
ground running without having to
reinvent the wheels even if they've made
breakthroughs it could take another 10
or 20 years to test out all the new
parts and get to the point where it's
economically viable right
your plan was to not have anything new
just is to use the oldest possible
technology that's been been proven and
so your I mean why should people care
about last energy because you're what
you're putting it together in some new
way it's a Technology Innovation from a
systems integration perspective we
productized nuclear
the challenge with new physics
Innovations it's not just the 10 years
to get past the physics part and then
another 10 years to get past the
engineering part the problem is if your
materials if your supply chain deviate
from what's common and scaled across
many other Industries you might never be
economical okay so so um have you sold
any of these yet so we probably had more
Commercial Success than every other new
nuclear startup combined just this last
year we've ended up signing contracts
throughout Eastern Europe and Poland
Romania and now also in the UK as some
of our early Target markets we have over
two dozen projects under development
across Europe and you've accomplished
this just as a startup I mean I was led
to believe that the nuclear new nuclear
was going to be still years and years
away and that you would need only the
biggest companies would be able to make
it happen if you're trying to do too
much okay trying to reinvent components
or technology almost all of the nuclear
startups start with a perspective that
there's something wrong with the reactor
okay well that takes thousands of people
to solve the reactor problem but if you
just use the existing reactor technology
like you can see behind me here then
with just a 40 person company you can
make this type of commercial headlight
my understanding is that you know you
don't have a PhD in nuclear science or
anything
um you're you're an entrepreneur your
previous company involved using drones
to study rooftops for insurance
companies how in the world did you go
from that to to this yeah so I have an
educational background in mechanical
engineering and then entrepreneurial
experience and a hard tech company and
Frontier Tech and building your own
technology but after selling that
company in 2017 and wanting to focus on
global scale challenges such as energy
and climate I took my time studying the
industry Met meeting with hundreds of
experts first in climate and then when
realizing that nuclear was just totally
misunderstood totally under leverage
ended up taking thousands more subject
matter expert interviews just in the
nuclear sector away and so the right
problem was
shrinking the enormous nuclear power
plants that we have around the world
into a more manageable size that was our
solution the problem that we discovered
was construction complexity okay so just
the time it takes the interest accrued
on your financing charges over that
construction period this ended up we
realized historically leading to most of
the cost of nuclear energy and so that
became the problem to solve
constructability not reactor physics
because problems have led people to
think that nuclear is just not going to
be affordable what you found is that it
can be very affordable if you shrink it
all and use only these off-the-shelf
parts go small go repeatable and then
build your way up to scale economies of
many instead of the economies of size
that's our approach I think people's
perception of nuclear has definitely
change dramatically over the last few
years really understanding as we start
to scale up these renewable systems some
of their shortcomings the land
consumption material consumption they
themselves have a carbon footprint and
then when you layer all the
environmental benefits of nuclear on top
of the energy Security benefits that
we're seeing ever more present
throughout Europe in today's day and age
nuclear is becoming the obvious choice
and I think both people and governments
are coming around I mean we know they
are because they came to us looking for
solutions they came to you in particular
these Eastern European countries in part
because after Russia's invasion of
Ukraine and the shutoff of gas to Europe
they realize we need other Solutions we
can't just dig more coal to make ends
meet they always knew that there was an
energy security threat and we've been
talking to many of these Eastern
European countries Romania and Poland
for many years it was just with the war
it became real to everybody how serious
a concerned energy security was so they
were able to put their political support
behind the projects that they always
wanted to anyway because energy security
became a threat to the public that the
public was aware of as well and so yes
within a month of the war breaking out
in Ukraine we got a call from the prime
minister of Romania himself came out and
he cleared room for two of our projects
at the miovanni research reactor site
now when we look at some of the biggest
obstacles to nuclear we've got
regulatory issues financing issues
um how are you going to pay for things
what's this going to cost anyway yeah so
each one of these units costs us under
100 million dollars to build and it
produces billions of dollars worth of
electricity over its lifetime the way
that we have architected our business
model is using what's common in the
Renewables industry known as a power
purchase agreement so what we do is we
get our customer usually a factory of
some sort whether it be aluminum or
glass or cement we get them to sign us
up as their utility they write us a
contract saying here's the price of
power over this period of time we then
take that contract to the financial
markets to private Equity infrastructure
funds they fund the capex of the
facility and then we both benefit from
the electricity sales and the profits of
it over time you said that that's the
way that renewable energy has has grown
indeed a
a factory is not going to own its own
solar panels or wind turbines right they
they contract through that long-term
power purchase agreement how many years
are we talking 20 years 30 years the
contracts that we have in Poland right
now are for 24-year period so this this
is the mock-up of course but the plant
would be operating for 24 years is that
the average lifespan the plant's
lifetime is 42 years however uh with
these power purchase agreements it's
much more common for them to be 5 10 or
20 or power purchase agreements it
sounds to me like that would incentivize
you
in a different way than utility
companies perhaps because you know if
I'm if I'm a big utility company
building a nuclear power plant I know
that if I have cost overruns I can just
charge my rate payers that money
um I don't have to eat it myself but if
you're going to continue to own the
plant I mean that must incentivize you
to really keep the costs contained
us having ownership from concept through
operation through decommissioning is a
perfect alignment of incentives it means
that from the design itself we're
designing for affordable electricity
we're designing with decommissioning in
mind we're designing the throughout the
entire plants we've designed the system
from the get-go to consider the entire
plant's lifetime at the end of the
lifetime of this plant you're going to
have a lot of nuclear waste I imagine
that's that's a big concern of a lot of
people they're still skeptical skeptical
about the safety of of a nuclear how do
you deal with that issue
most of the safety concerns are
perception based rather than resulting
from the physical phenomena of the plant
yes it's radioactive but it's not that
radioactive after you shut it down the
heat dissipates very quickly the
radioactivity also that's the magic of
radioactivity it magically disappears
all on its own and So within just a few
months iodine 131 which is the
radionuclide that has a hazard human
health all gone okay so all of a sudden
you've eliminated the health hazard
within just a few months of waiting
within 10 years most of the heat is gone
and so we've designed our system this
exact same modular frame with
decommissioning in mind to be able to
take it apart just as easily as you put
it together and bring it to whatever
waste storage facility or recycling
center you want to bring it to we've
designed our reactor vessel itself to be
like a battery cartridge and we've
designed the facility this nuclear
island with extra battery slots so in
every six years we come in with a new
battery cartridge a fully fueled reactor
vessel drop it into place plug it in and
run it for another six years we do that
same thing seven times throughout the
lifetime in the facility and then we let
it cool down and then the whole facility
can be packaged up so you don't have to
remove the the spent fuel rods they just
stay they stay here the whole time that
is one of the key differences in the
operational Paradigm between us and the
standard technology with the standard
pwr technology you open up the reactor
vessel you Shuffle the fuel you add new
fuel for us we don't we simply drop in a
new battery cartridge fully fueled what
would be the biggest obstacles that you
still have to overcome in order to get
the first one of these operating yeah so
we've checked off most of the boxes from
everything from government approval to
technology development manufacturability
is what we're testing right here but
there are still steps along the way this
mechanical prototype will advance we're
going to test out the disassembly next
the transportability and continue to
make these design enhancements all
serving a greater mission of scalable
easy to construct reducing complexity to
deliver the most affordable clean power
that you could imagine okay so each one
of these units will will produce how
much electricity 20 megawatts it's about
the size of a data center or a Pulp and
Paper Factory or an automotive
manufacturers but a big old old school
nuclear those are how many megawatts a
thousand a gigawatt yeah a thousand
megawatts about the size of a million
person City whereas as ours would serve
a town about the size of 20 000 people
but if I want more of them I can build
you can build them in parallel and
that's the other change in the
operational power time another area that
we're Innovative is borrowing lessons
learned from other Industries when you
build a solar farm you don't build one
giant solar panel you build the same
solar panel over and over again you
stack them next to each other the exact
same with our micro nuclear facilities
if you need 200 megawatts we're going to
install 10 identical 20 megawatt units
right next to each other so like you're
saying it's counterintuitive you might
give up a little bit of efficiency
because your units are smaller but
you're making that up in the ease of
manufacturing and installation exactly
since there's nothing really new here
what's your what's last energies
intellectual property well there's still
quite a bit of technical complexity on
the systems integration the
modularization the manufacturability
these are all incredible technical
challenges to overcome but the rule that
we sell for ourselves is no component
level innovation no new physics no
chemistry no new material science that
those are the sexy and the fun problems
that people gravitate towards instead we
chose the still technical
problems but the boring ones okay so
your intellectual property isn't how to
put it all together and and transport it
to the other side of the world and how
much electricity we get from nuclear my
understanding is there's something like
300 or 400 nuclear power plants around
the world and they put out roughly 400
or 500 gigawatts of power does that
sound right this is what is just so
incredible about nuclear technology it's
that for so little input you get so much
out of it okay and so those 400 400
buildings around the world provide 10 of
world's electricity four percent of all
of our energy consumption as a global
civilization that's incredible from 400
buildings but the fact is that any
any society that has experienced a rapid
decarbonization whether you look at
France or Sweden or South Korea or
Ontario they've anyone that's done a
total decarbonization of their energy
infrastructure and under decades time
it's always been nuclear they still rely
on coal especially in Poland especially
Romania they're I think the majority of
their electricity from from coals still
so your initial customer base are people
companies that no longer want to rely on
on dirty Coal Power are the factories
that we serve in Poland specifically
have two problems the first is that yes
their energy that they get is very
expensive and very dirty and the other
is actually capacity because it's not so
easy to just string up new transmission
lines and so they want to grow their
economy they want to grow their industry
and they literally cannot get enough
power to the factory so what do we do we
ship over a bunch of shipping container
size modules put it right next to the
factory and we become their utility
nuclear has yet again another very
unique advantage and it's called
distributed base load the fact that you
can perfectly match your power supply
with your power demand both in location
and in time if a city needs 400
megawatts of power they can buy 20 of
our 20 megawatt units and co-locate that
with the city so you don't even need
transmission cabling at all if they grow
in terms of size they can just add on
another unit so it's always perfectly
matched and you don't you don't think
those the citizens of that town should
worry about having all those reactors
right in the fields right next door I
think part of the reason that some
communities have grown skeptical or
scared of nuclear it's actually lack of
exposure to it and so by building these
beautiful buildings and setting them up
outside of town and inviting the
community to come visit it we're going
to be changing the perception of nuclear
as well I hope that's I hope that's true
once you've built up a dozen of these in
Eastern Europe
do you think the NRC might just want to
you know rubber stamp it and say you
know this is good for the U.S too I
think after we've built a few of these
in Eastern Europe we're going to end
Western Europe as well we're going to
see interest from around the entire
world and it's going to be a race to see
who can get their hands on as many of
these as soon as possible that'll be a
good problem for you to have okay how
many of these do you think you could
build over the next decade our goal is
to completely decarbonize Earth's energy
production period we want to make energy
abundant and affordable because of the
effects that it has for every other
industry I mean if you think of data
centers or if you think of material
production if you think of all of the
modern wonders of Life they all have
energy as a root input to them and so by
us making energy cheaper we're going to
help fill the visions of every other
industry as well there's certainly some
institutional inertia that is slowed
down from a bureaucratic perspective the
development of new nuclear installations
in this contrary it applies less to us
because we're focused on Europe and in
Europe we've had a lot of success
working with the NRC equivalent
Regulators so the onr out in the UK
chinacon and Romania and the paa in
Poland have been great Partners in
helping us regulate and Implement our
nuclear technology abroad when you're
talking tens of thousands of reactors
that seems like an awful lot of material
a lot of uranium and everything else is
that going to be a limiting factor at
all
one of the Beauties about a system as
simple as ours that's not moving towards
these radical new physics innovations
that require new materials is that our
plant is essentially steel copper water
and uranium all of some of the most
abundant and available materials
especially in terms of the power
production that they end up creating
there's more than enough from a material
perspective for us to not only satisfy
Global energy demand but for us to 10x
it for wind turbines and solar panels
they need a lot of
exotic materials rare earth metals and
stuff like that you don't need any of
those there is a challenge in these
systems that require you know big
magnets with some of these more exotic
materials but they also require steel
and cement and other things too that are
material concerns the key is with
nuclear you get so much more for so much
less input okay and so for us to produce
that exact same megawatt hour of energy
as a renewable system we'd be using
between 100 and a thousand times less
material input
for the same amount of electricity the
same amount of electricity you're
looking at a facility right now that can
supply energy for 20 000 homes if you
were to think of all the solar panels
you'd need you'd have a great visual
representation of just how much more
material and land Renewables require you
have some competitors out there other
companies have spent hundreds of
millions of dollars and many more years
to try to get through the regulatory
process and they they don't really seem
to be any further along than you this
guy who only got into the field four or
five years ago
um what are what are they missing what
do you attribute your success to so far
I mean for sure you haven't built this
yet but you've made some great progress
one of our core Theses is to always make
sure that you're solving the right
problem not the fun one and so we went
around we interviewed both people from
industry government scientists and
former startups in the nuclear in the
nuclear sector itself
and one thing that we realized was
everyone was just so focused on
redesigning the reactor and come on it's
fun especially if you're a nuclear
physicist that's what you're trained to
do redesign and react what do you mean
like new kinds of fuel or new
configurations new fuel Fusion everyone
loves that yeah so fundamentally new
physics as well Forbes of course we
cover the world billionaires
when it comes to Fusion I'm amazed at
how many billionaires want to have a
piece of one Fusion development or
another it's like that it's their pet
rock right now
um do you have any billionaire backers
yet
um I don't know if I should be speaking
to the personal finances of our backers
but we've got an amazing cohort of
investors and board members all of our
investors were former entrepreneurs and
operators themselves and yes they've
done extremely well over the years so
what's 2023 going to hold for last
energy what are your Milestones to reach
this year Well 2022 was incredible you
know between getting head of state
endorsements and selling dozens of units
abroad it was just like a whirlwind year
so now it's time to get to brass tacks
ramp up our manufacturing capabilities
and start actually serving these Energy
Systems and your manufacturing is going
to initially be done where right here in
Texas here in Texas thanks a lot for
being with us today yeah thank you so
much
foreign
[Music]